[Music]
the debate about police reform has
divided many communities but there is
widespread agreement that sending mental
health professionals to help people in
crisis with or without police backup is
a good idea one study found people with
untreated mental illness are 16 times
more likely to be killed during an
encounter with officers jeff pagas takes
us inside one colorado community's
experiment with alternative ways to
handle mental health crises
across the country police officers are
increasingly responding to mental health
related calls
that don't always require an armed
response we received a call from your
school today i just wanted to touch base
aurora colorado is a team of health
professionals separate from the police
who are now dispatched to some emergency
calls there were some statements about
suicide that were made to a friend
yesterday
especially when it's determined that an
armed officer is not needed
stop by and check in with her so they
got a 911 call and that's why we're here
in this neighborhood it came from a
school counselor concerned about the
safety of a student
we rode along with this mobile response
team
as it traveled through the city's
snow-covered streets once they arrived
in the area they reached out to the
students i spoke with mom
and spoke with kiddo and we don't have
any concerns for safety at this time in
the past police would have responded to
the call
sergeant aaron bunch acknowledges that
there are limits to what police officers
are trained to do
so
we have calls for people that are in
mental health crisis every day
police officers are trained to do a lot
of things what they don't have are
master's degrees in social work
clinical psychology things like that
courtney tassin who is the response
team's program manager says there were
more than 800 mental health-related
calls for help here during a recent
four-month period the fact that you're
not armed the fact that you're not
wearing a uniform do you think that
helps in some of these situations i
think so so we always focus on what's
least restrictive how do we keep from
further traumatizing this person who's
already in a very vulnerable state
thousands of police departments in
america are now using similar units to
respond to people experiencing a mental
health crisis you're at this location
now when the person is threatening you
in washington d.c 9-1-1 calls are
screened to determine if mental health
professionals are the more suitable
response what was the threat
[Music]
to prevent a mental health crisis from
escalating into a fatal confrontation
for cbs morning's jeff begaye's aurora
colorado
really smart
but you got it's got a fund from so
there's got to find some funding
somewhere for units like this yeah yeah
when i was young i was fascinated by the
negotiator the guy or woman that would
go in and talk down the criminal as i
got older i realized we need negotiators
when it comes to dealing with those that
are dealing with mental illness or
having an episode
because they are knowledgeable in that
space and some of these officers like he
said they're not equipped mentally to
handle that system and also cops sign up
to fight criminals and crimes right they
don't want to deal with people in mental
health crises that's a different task
yeah good way to try to avoid some of
what we've seen before